Một chẳng tại chính Mỹ Scott Ben-San Trumeet, Washington và Mắc Kinh đã đạt được thoả thận khung
lên quan đến hạt động của tích tóc tại Mỹ. Theo đó, nên tảng này sẽ được chuyển sâm mô hình xử hiệu dọc
biệm miệng kinh sọt, tuy nhiên các chi tích của kùm của thật sẽ được tổng thống đúng năng trâm và chủ tích tập cật bình,
anh định trong cuộc định đâm dự kiến dễ dàng ngày bù chỉ tả chính.
Đến bố của Ben-San đưa ra trong bố cảnh tích tóc lối mặt mùi cơ bị cấm tại Mỹ từng là Mỹ Hoại tháng chính,
nếu công ty máy Biden không từ bỏ quên sở hiệu tại Mỹ,
đại dễ thăm máy Mỹ trên bình sình gửi cho biết chính quyền Mỹ có thể giá hạn thay hạn này để bảo đam quá chính đã phán được phán tất.
Ngài tích tóc là tâm điểm vong lối thoại tại Madrid dựa Mỹ và Trung Quốc từ ngày mấy bốn đến mấy bại tháng chính,
còn để cập đến các bình đề thời quan hợp tác trong dự tiền và ngăn chạp bộ bà mà tuy yp eta niên.
Bố trường tại chính Mỹ Scott Ben-San Trumeet,
hãy nhớ có thể tiếp tục đổi thoại trong tình tựa về phía Trung Quốc,
trong đoạn đà phán là phó thuật tưởng hà lập phong kêu gọi Mỹ sớm dựa bỏ hạn chế thu mai,
nhấn mại sự ôn định trong qua hệ hệ hải nền kinh tế lớn nhất thế giới,
mạng ý nghĩa tháng chốt với tăng chực kinh tế tòa gầu.